it all happened so fast we have to stop  them Batman  whatever they are they're going to  regret stepping foot and Gotham  this is our big score gentlemen get the  bat fire fire  do I look like a friggin bat to you  [Music]  I've read rumors about a supernatural  back creature in Gotham but I assumed it  was an urban legend Ninja Turtles we  came to Gotham to stop shredder and the  Foot Clan  [Music]  the man who'll help us destroy this city  is right behind this door  [Laughter]  Robin Batgirl these inmates were the  deadliest criminals in all of Gotham  let's move  it's time for this city to destroy  himself take him down we need answers  you're welcome to try he thought too  fast  we're not your enemy this is still my  city  if they're ready for a fight we bring on  a freakin fight  what no match for me